what is going on there reject nation
greg here today we are going to watch
the trailer the red band one for the
boys season three i love the hell out of
this show i heard the boys diabolical's
great my friend paul from heavy spoilers
recommends it immensely it's covered
some breakdowns for you guys should go
check it out yeah i haven't seen any of
the boys since we reacted to the finale
whenever the heck that was regardless
i'm very much excited for this i'm glad
my boy jensen ackles is joining this
show sam dude gotta do both you just
gotta do both sam and dean anyway guys
if you could leave a like i'd very much
appreciate that i know yeah john's out
here because he had surgery the other
day so he's out of commission for a few
days but
let's watch the stone together
[Music]
but sure
[Music]
did take some compound b
this is definitely magic dragons too
recognize that voice
[Music]
oh interesting interesting
oh good for you man
[Music]
there he was
cool
must be trying to level the playing
field
[Music]
milking oh
[Music]
man
that was definitely homelander versus
butcher sir
[Music]
my boy's back with kripke can't wait man
can't wait gosh you know the boys is
already fantastic but if you're a
supernatural fan
much better
i'm only on season 9 of supernatural
recovery on patreon so uh still got like
25 more seasons left to go there's a lot
of that trailer let's uh let's talk
about it i mean first thoughts right off
the bat when i saw that promo image of
butcher with the the vision eyes the
laser eyes i thought that was just some
like you know promo material or
something i didn't think it was gonna be
an actual thing where he would have
superpowers so it seems like he'd be
taking compound v perhaps to help level
the playing field he's probably going to
the point after the death of becca that
in order for him to finally take down
homelander he would probably need some
superpowers in order to do it just going
to kind of comb through this trailer and
see what i can pick up i'm loving all
these glimpses that we've been getting
of homelanders because this performance
of him and at least in this brief images
that we got in after the events of last
season he just seems incredibly
emasculated it's the way i probably
surmise the performance of anthony stars
of lake who i hear can really hold down
his liquor incredibly well you get this
interesting shot of huey early on which
if i'm not mistaken he joins newman's
campaign at the end of season two still
in like a suit and ties i don't know
this looks like it could be him maybe
early on learning the truth about newman
the trailer was going by so fast so i'm
not even sure if we saw her i'm assuming
she'd probably be like one of the the
main baddies for this particular season
we got to unpack that as well there
you'll see this is where you guys come
and help me out three beautiful sobs
come in is this uh mother's milk looking
for someone specific i see a sign here
that says superhero or slayer kind of
looks like jensen ackles up there at the
top but i can't really tell there is an
image here of soldier boy right in front
of him maybe he's tracking down soldier
but what i've read up on about soldier
boy he's essentially a play on like
captain america part of a team called
payback which eric kripke describes as
payback was the seven before the seven
they were like the world's first
superhero team during world war ii and
we're gonna be exploring the history of
that team looks like we'll be dealing a
lot with flashbacks but the same time
towards the end of this trailer it seems
like perhaps that they are doing
something that's like a major riff on
captain america in the sense of like
he's from the past but now he's brought
back to the present perhaps resurrected
or he was frozen or something like that
like he was gone for for decades and now
he's back you're gonna be seeing other
characters from that team called payback
like in the trailer you saw this
character named crimson countess who has
heat vision and can manipulate fire what
i was reading up on is that soldier boy
he was part of the payback team he was
technically team leader but was
disrespected and overpowered by
stormfront that's right stormfront was
on his tame so in comparison he was a
little bit weak to her and he always
wanted a spot in the seven and it's
freaking jensen axles man okay i'm so
excited to know
this moment here with atran looks like
it's a spoof on that college jedi
except he's got turbo rush instead of
pepsi this moment here i was reading up
on that there's gonna be some type of
reality show called i think it's called
an american hero it's gonna be a
competition show where there's like 10
supes who are fighting for one of the
spots of the seven and that this guy
right here is a character named
supersonic who is starlight's
ex-boyfriend reportedly which i'm sure
will create some wonderful tension looks
like ashley and the director of what's
oh you do get this one moment here i
can't tell if that's newman who's
exploding this person is that newman
looks like newman i do think that this
shot right here where you go into the
deep's eyes is the moment where we will
finally see brought to live action the
thing that everyone's been talking about
since the season was announced herogasm
so in herogasm homelander announces that
like the the superheroes of earth are
banning together to fight an alien
invasion in space but when they end up
doing is actually they fly to like a
remote island for a wild ass orgy and in
reality that's where john's at right now
he didn't need surgery he just wanted to
party never invites me to the damn
orgies and then the boys got to like
infiltrate that mission i don't know how
i've seen some images of it and i don't
know how you even for amazon like that's
pretty risque but eric kripke has a lot
of confidence in the script that they
have that they can really pull this one
off and i actually seen the deep there
who uh this is probably a very
triggering moment for him and he's
probably gonna really spiral downhill
into this
this liquid abyss i mean they would have
this moment here with the deep where
he's like dude with a girl
oh god that is uh that is hilarious but
then of course at the center of all
butcher homelander going toe-to-toe with
each other either way this trailer is
awesome i love the hell out of this
trailer i thought it was really violent
gazillion details that i'm sure flew way
over my head i can't wait for the show
man guys what did you think about it
leave your thoughts down below are you
excited for the boys season three
subscribe click the notification bell
leave a like and uh last month let's do
it
anis oliver i gotta shout you out in
this video because you're the one who
gave me this shirt now nissa i know that
when it's just me on camera you're very
disappointed you're all about that john
you're wishing you're part of that
herogasm party with him right now but
with me you'll get sincerity
you would not participate in the
herogasm if i was i just know i could
have
reality i was saying you messed me in a
while say hello i don't know what your
deal is it's kind of bothering me
because i thought i said i would do
sincerity but it's not happening i am
planning on trying to go to texas there
are people who i want to collab with out
there there's a studio of a certain
youtuber who i'm like i want to be on
your channel and i would like to go out
there and he said i could stay at his
place and i found out it's in the same
area where you live when john and i go
out there we do got to pay you a visit
we got to hang out
buy you a beer and it's going to be a
great time plenty of alcohol required
you're one of the best people in the
world i've ever known i mean that
sincerely i'll never forget everything
you've done for us over the years looks
like it's finally happening i'll finally
meet in person i know you'll only
respond to that meetup if john messages
you directly fine whatever all right bye
anissa
[Music]